[Music]  look familiar if someone you love  clinging desperately that about a barely  able to function hitting their rock  bottom so it's time to get help because  your baby has a drinking problem at  beginners Recovery Center in Malibu your  baby can break the cycle of milk  dependency on his or her own terms  while he begins to understand this  addiction through programs like art  therapy have been heard restraint  exercises inner strength and higher  power personal growth activities and  group therapy with guest lectures  sharing their own right and will make  sure your baby's cycle of addiction  stays broken with random room checks  from a concerned and highly trained  staff we get your name on a post for  understanding his addiction so he may  begin to make math and eventually find  his new beginning while successfully  navigating the minefield of old  temptations and the Dolores  beginnings Recovery Center it's never  too soon to start over  [Music]  [Applause]  you